بييي لذا فان التعاون مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومع العاهل السعودي والامير محمد
بن سلمان بالنسبه الينا مهم
[موسيقى]
للغايه السعوديه تعلنها لا شيء لواشنطن
وكل ما نملكه سيكون رهن اشاره بوتين اوهو
ما هو المقابل يا هذا وكاني اجتم رائحه
اليورانيوم المعتق تملا المكان وفي الجهه
المقابله الامريكان في صدمه ليصرح ذلك
العجوز الهرم لقد سقطت الخليج من ايدينا
لتظهر على السطح رائحه التهديد والوعيد
ونقصد الوفد الامريكي الذي وصل الى دبي
تاركا محمد بن زايد في حاله هلع وخوف ما
الذي يدور تحت الطاوله يا هؤلاء السعوديه
تحد شفرات سيفها معلنه اقامه الحد على
الدولار الاحداث السياسيه الساخنه اذا
فالامر يحتاج الى كوب من القهوه الساخنه
لا يقل سخونه عن الاحداث التي سنشاهدها في
هذا الفيديو انتزع انياب
واشنطن لم يظن العم سام ان هذا اليوم
الاسود سياتي بهذه السرعه فبعد دعوه
السعوديه للانضمام الى مجموعه بريكس اتحدت
مليارات الذهب الاسود مع القوه العسكريه
الغاشمه لتكتب ن سويا شهاده وفاه الهيمنه
الامريكيه جاء اعلان خفض انتاج النفط الذي
تبنته المملكه في ابريل الماضي لتخفض
انتاجها من عشره الى 9 ملايين برميل يوميا
ولكن لم يكتفي ملوك الذهب الاسود بذلك لان
النتيجه لم ترضي بوتين لتتلقى صفعه على
الخد الاخر نعم فتدرج اصبح انتاج المملكه
من النفط لا يتعدى سوى 7 ملايين ونصف
المليون برميل لتمر ايام قليله ويستقبل
الامريكان صدمه اخرى كادت ان تفقدهم الوعي
وبحسب موقع اويل برايس قررت المملكه تخفيض
انتاجها من النفط ليصبح 5 ملايين ونصف
المليون برميل يوميا فقط حتى نهايه العام
يا الهي انه ليس مجرد خفض انتاج بل هو
سقوط حر
وسيتلقى
بالاحمر ماذا تريد يا بن سلمان ومن تعهد
لك بتحمل كل تلك الخسائر
اعلان عن تنظيم قد تقول يا عزيزي ان
المملكه تفعل هذا من اجل قاعده قله العرض
وزياده الطلب لرفع سعر برميل النفط خصوصا
وان ان سعر البرميل حاليا قد قفز ليتخطى
حاجز 90 دولارا ولكن الامر ليس كذلك بل
سنكتفي ان نقول لك ان سياسه بن سلمان
النفطيه حاليا هي اشبه باللعب بالبيضه
والحجر فقد تفقد الرياض مكانتها النفطيه
الكبرى لصالح باقي منتج النفط الذين سيغرق
الاسواق بانتاج مهلا مهلا لا ننسى ان
السعوديه تمتلك حق القرار في مجموعه اوبيك
بلس وكما يقولها المصري
اللي مالوش كبير يشتري كبير والسعوديه
والخليج اشترت روسيا والصين وهما المتحكم
تان حاليا بهذا السوق فماذا يريد ملوك
الذهب الاسود يقول موقع اويل برايس ان
سياسه السعوديه النفطيه الحاليه ليست فقط
من اجل رفع سعر البرميل بل هي اعلان صريح
عن تنظيم بريكس الجديد نعم الكل يعرف هذه
المجموعه ولكن بريكس بعد انضمام السعوديه
لن تكون هي نفسها بريكس قبل انضمام
المملكه يبدو ان الدب الروسي سيستعين
بالسيف السعودي لذبح الدولار الامريكي
فانضم السعوديه والامارات وايران لبريكس
برعايه بوتين وتشين جينج بينغ يعني سيطره
المجموعه على اكثر من 40% من انتاج النفط
العالمي واظن ان تركيا راضيه لتتوجه
الاعين صوب قطر لترتفع النسبه الى
67% وستستكمل المصيبه على راس العم سام
عندما يتم الاعلان عن عمله بريكس الموحده
والتي ستستخدم في التجاره الدوليه بين
اعضاء المنظمه ليس هذا فقط بل ماذا لو
علمت ان اكثر من 30 دوله كبرى تريد
الانضمام الى بريكس وان المجموعه تتوسع
سنويا ليتكون الحلف الذي ربما سيقضي على
الهيمنه الامريكيه بضربه قاضيه فدول
كالجزائر مثلا احدى اكثر الدول طموحا
ونفوذا في افريقيا اليوم وان لم تتم
دعوتها للانضمام الى بريكس هذه المره فمن
المتوقع دعوتها للانضمام الى المجموعه
خلال العام القادم ناهيك عن عشرات الدول
التي تسبح في بحار من الطاقه واغلبها
تنتظر اشاره بوتين والحكيم الصيني للحاق
بالمركب احذر يا بايدن فالدبر سي والتنين
الصيني لا يمزحان ليتن حنحكي جوز الطاعن
في السن مصرحا في ياس اصبحت لا املك حلولا
انا في انتظار معجزه فعن اي معجزه نتحدث
يا بايدن طوق النجاه ترى واشنطن ان الامل
الوحيد الذي يبقيها على قيد الحياه في
المنطقه الذهبيه هو موافقه السعوديه على
تطبيع العلاقات مع اسرائيل لدرجه ان وفدا
امريكيا ذهب الى السعوديه وهناك عقد
اجتماع ثلاثي مع وفد فلسطيني وشخصيات
سعوديه على مستوى رفيع كل هذا من اجل
اذابه الجليد والتمهيد لخطوه التطبيع التي
ينتظرها بايدن على احر من الجمر حتى ان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سيلوفان
قال السلام بين السعوديه واسرائيل يعد
صفقه كبيره فسوف يصنع ظروفا يمكن لدول
المنطقه من خلالها التعاون في جميع
الاشياء وسوف يفيد هذا الولايات المتحده
بشكل اساسي لان لدينا مصلحه في ذلك انها
المعجزه التي ينتظرها العم مسام لتعيده
الى الشرق الاوسط بل قلت يده الى الحياه
من جديد فتطبيق المملكه مع اسرائيل يعني
ابعاد الدب الروسي والتنين الصيني عن
المشهد لتعود المملكه الى عباءه واشنطن
ولكن هل تقدر واشنطن على شروط بن سلمان
للموافقه على التطبيع ضياع الامل في الوقت
الذي تحاول فيه واشنطن الوصول الى شيء مرد
لبن سلمان جاءت الصدمه على يد الكاتب
الامريكي توماس فريدمان والذي كتب في
صحيفه النيويورك تايمز قائلا رهان
الولايات المتحده على تطبيع السعودي
الاسرائيلي من اجل حل ازماتها في الشرق
الاوسط يعد دربا من الغباء
فالحكومة الوديه كبش الفداء كما يقول
المثل المصري اضرب المربوط يخاف السايب
رات واشنطن ان لابد لها من التضحيه لتعيد
هيبتها في المنطقه ووجدت ضالتها في
الامارات فبن زايد قد لحق ببن سلمان الى
بريكس ويبدو انه يخطط ليرتمي في احضان
الدب الروسي والاحتماء به هو الاخر خصوصا
وان حجم التجاره بين الامارات والسعوديه
تخطت عشره المليارات دولار وهو مستوى غير
مسبوق بل ان البضائع التي تدخل روسيا عن
طريق الامارات تعتبر تكنولوجيا غربيه على
احدث مستوى لا تريد واشنطن واوروبا ان تقع
في يد موسكو ولان واشنطن لا تريد استفزاز
الرياض خصوصا في هذه المرحله قامت بتوجيه
سيطها هذه المره الى ابو ظبي امله ان تنجح
في تراجع الامارات عن بريكس وترك يد بوتين
وعسى ايضا ان تخاف السعوديه هي الاخرى فقد
نشرت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال قال فضحت فيه
زياره مرتقبه لوفد امريكي بريطاني الى
الامارات اجتماعهم ببن زايد لا يا عزيزي
ليست زياره عاديه بل هم مسؤولوا العقوبات
بامريكا والاتحاد الاوروبي سيذهبون الى
الامارات للتاكيد على العقوبات المفروضه
على روسيا وتهديد بن زايد بعقوبات قويه
ستفرض عليه اذا ما استمرت في سياسه
التقارب مع موسكو حسب الصحيفه صحيح انه
حتى الان لا احد يعرف ان كان كانت الزياره
قد تمت ام لا وما هي تفاصيل هذا الاجتماع
السري ولكن من المؤكد ان واشنطن تحاول
الضغط على طرف الاضعف في اللعبه فربما
يراجع بن سلمان نفسه اذا راى جاره يتراجع
امام الضغط الغربي اما الان السؤال لكم
مشاهدينا هل ترون ان المملكه ستستمر في
التدفق بالعباءه الروسيه ام ان جعبه العمي
سام لا تزال تحوي اوراقا جديده ستقلب
موازين اللعبه راسا على عق
ننتظر
[موسيقى]
تعليقاتكم